ça la contre-offensive ukrainienne
vladimir poutine choisi l'escaladent
dans une adresse retransmises à la
télévision russe mercredi le chef du
kremlin des noms selon ses mots un
chantage nucléaire de l'occident et
menace
est jouable je tiens à vous rappeler que
notre pays dispose également de diverses
armes de destruction et à certains
égards elles sont même plus moderne que
celle des pays de l'otan
s'il ya une menace pour l'intégrité
territoriale de notre pays afin de
protéger la russie et notre peuple nous
utiliserons certainement tous les moyens
à notre disposition ce n'est pas du
bluff depuis presque un mois l'armée
ukrainienne a lancé une vaste
contre-offensive et repris des dizaines
de localités à l'armée russe ce mercredi
vladimir poutine autorise aussi une
mobilisation partielle c'est à dire
l'envoi d'environ 300 milles réservistes
vers le front ukrainien pour le ministre
britannique de la défense ben wallace
cette mobilisation est un aveu d'échec
et montre que l'ukraine est en train de
gagner pour l'union européenne c'est le
signe du désarroi de vladimir poutine
pour le chancelier allemand elle montre
que l' attaque russe en ukraine n'est
pas couronnée de succès enfin vladimir
poutine a également confirmé la tenue de
référendums d'annexion dans les
républiques séparatistes de dounia est
louhansk et les régions occupées de
zappos rizhao personnes